Jimmy how has the markets began to price
in this potential trade war we talked to
a few analysts and strategists in the
past few days and they are warning that
the markets in both China and the United
States are yet to pricing a significant
impact of a rising trade disputes
between the two largest economies so how
do they think that the market will cope
in a worst-case scenario say if a trade
war just breaks out and we see
retaliation from both sides yes under
the worst case scenario according to
Morgan Stanley they are seeing actually
China and the United States levy 45
percent text on the imported goods on
each other so under that case the MSE a
China index is likely to for as much as
30 percent from the current level and
according to the Balkan internationals
forecasts the Shanghai Composite Index
may quickly for below that 200 mm and
800 level that's 10% from the current
level yeah I mean we've heard about the
45 percent tariff but at least Trump
hasn't mentioned that again when it
comes to this potential trade wars who
could be most affected you know from the
China perspective the producers of food
well consumer electronics and and a
Paris so those kind of products are
among the most exported goods to the US
so those makers would be heavily
impacted so companies like GE Lenovo
would be among the biggest losers so
from the US side so electronics
companies that derives a large share of
revenues from the China markets could be
among the biggest losers and also
somewhere known brands in the US like
Nike for mortos General Motors Tiffany
so people are thinking you know there
could be a boycotts by the Chinese
customers if they're Ferris rising
tensions between the to come